- hello my foo / troopers at his I your
Lord Commander the one true feeling you
look over it he was not down for all the
pomp and uh mm-hmm
grandiose right you just want to get
into it humble humble I think it is me
your humble servant ethan klein your one
true humble servant today's episode is
sponsored by hems and Noom thank you to
them for sponsoring us he knows funny
when I said and today I was like you
know that anti OOP stuff was really
popular everybody was really liking all
the anti ooping and all that stuff and I
guess people were quoting me and I'm
such an idiot
I surprised myself I go I go people
really like this joke I made about and
on the seventh day God said and I
because there were a lot of comments
invited like quoting me I was like wow
people thought that was super funny I
then I and then they were all like
that's what you told everybody to say at
the end of the show to prove that they
listened and I was like oh my god being
that stupid that you tell people to do
it and then you forget about it and then
the next day you think they're just
flattering you because you're funny I
mean I think it's the well everyone says
the mom brain but I guess there's a dad
brain - I got dad brain sister it's like
you start forgetting everything I'm
noticing that - I think it us a lot of
sleep last night and it's so weird cuz
I'm not used to it so like someone will
say that I said something and I'm like
no there's no way I did and then I did
and I don't remember is that what you
feel like
ooping everyday yeah I mean I mean I was
just astounded I was like thinking
everyone thought I was funny but they
were just doing what I told them to do I
mean I mean that's like new levels of
Dom well anyway we got a great show for
you
today but it means they listened to the
part they're working so now knowing okay
yeah now knowing that I did tell them to
do that
there wasn't that enough because it was
like a couple of spattering like 15
lines so it means that not that many
people listened that beer okay which is
what I always suspected but this is the
good part this welcome to the first 30
minutes is what everyone listens to we
slowly deteriorate as the show today we
do have a heck of an episode planned if
I'd do say so myself
Belle Delphine is back I didn't want to
talk about Belle Delphine I was like a
dead horse but he was like we got to
talk about Belle Delphine it wasn't like
we talked about Belle delfino's like Zak
you have a girlfriend you shouldn't be
talking about this stuff but he insisted
we bought Zak a premium snapchat
membership for his birthday so he's all
amped up no I'm not I guess I wasn't
supposed to tell people that but Belle
and then I mean Trish's in the news she
got married we found out to whom big
surprise
it's a cutout of Brad Pitt as it pretty
much everyone predicted really I saw
everyone predicting who's like a
follower of hers that it was some
publicity stunt
yeah either people were guessing she was
gonna get married to herself which was a
good guess but then she just had a cut
you know what I bet happen ela is that
she was gonna get married to herself and
then she saw everybody knew what she was
gonna do so you got a card a cutout of
Breton it cuz it's not that funny cutout
of Brad Pitt yeah it's not what is there
I guess we'll talk about it
I don't yeah we've got the video mm-hmm
we've got L we had lots of complaints
about the candy tier list not about the
rating system in general of course
people like to nitpick your decisions
and it's a very controversial when it
comes to something like candy but we
I mean let's take a look at the table
here there was a lot of stuff we left
out I have to say unfairly so this
should do it
this is part two and this really ought
to do it we've got everything here and
some that I'm really excited about for
example warheads the ELA is not ready
for and candies so bizarre as fun dip
the ELA hat does it can't even perceive
what that could possibly be and it's
weird and it's it's gross okay but we'll
see it's disgusting but I mean like in
theory you'll see what I'm talking about
don't get ahead of ourselves here
there's so much to do so much to talk
about you guys let's just get right into
it
seesee and our favorite turkish chef is
in the mix in the mobility game yeah
turkey yeah the combining of best world
czn took a note out of our playbook and
he went out to rural turkey I guess and
hooked some homey up with a mobility
scooter Oh looks like a good one too at
first I thought it was the Gatsby how
many yeah it's got a little basket at
the front I was like bro what's the top
speed at a 30-degree incline he start
looking at him they have all these
specific [ __ ] like he's really tall by
the way czn huh so he brought a teddy
bears and he's really the guy I mean
it's a feel-good moment I'm not gonna
take that away from czn but it's also
kind of funny because I mean just look
at it and then he gives a teddy bear to
all the kids I mean he's a sweetheart
don't get me yeah I mean look at this
man I'm surprised how like the world
gets out there I mean I'm assuming
they're in Turkey I don't know where
they are but it looks like these monkeys
are living in actual goddamn mud huts I
was that puppy hooked me up brother also
he kept the guy he keeps kissing him
like he keeps hugging and kissing and I
mean it's a something that's normal it's
sweet but he just really he's hugging
the teddy bear he's like I mean he's a
grown man
it's my favorite it's very funny to me
I'm not trying to take away the good
nature of it it's funny anyone who
watches is gonna admit to me right now
that this is not that this is hilarious
seasons off the change giving a 50 year
old man a big teddy bear and he's
kissing the teddy bear and then kissing
him bro they're hooking up poppy seeds
dude let's that's sick let's get out
there the poppy field actually looks
like cotton if I'm being honest I mean
if that was poppy they should be in like
nicer houses even Khan what are they
doing out there why they live in a huts
they got a cash crop cotton right
where'd you see the HUD OCIO look at
their duck there yeah look at there oh
wow that's a house house but look at
look at okay hold on let me go back oh
look at this that's a house oh I thought
they were living in that no I'm an idiot
I'm an ignorant ignorant yeah I guess
they have houses and stuff I thought
they were out there like it's just rural
yeah that's like a farm town or
something I thought they were like sub
rural like look at that house look at
that I was like dude that dude lives in
there no what are they doing there it's
like Fresno to me that's true
what are you doing there eula yeah why
do they need electricity into this
storage storage I mean either way you
cut it that's pretty that's pretty rural
dude the cable is about to hit czn in
the head oh yeah I could find places
like that in his room that's true this
is where they need mobility scooters
damn smoke let me smoke that [ __ ] I
think you're I think you were right with
the second-guess it was a con yeah it's
cotton
they won if it was poppies there be
dudes with machine guns and [ __ ] there
wouldn't be all kissing and hugging over
the con this is a great crossover though
beam's we got czn & mobility scooters
one of the best crossovers of all time
what could you ask for
Oh it'sa but look what I mean it's so
funny you guys look here he goes in for
another kiss mwah and then they go and
they like lay in bed together and then I
guess it ends on the steam you know not
bad that's like a bit living room
you see that's their house look at that
what am i I'm not making up that's
pretty wild
yeah that's rural dude that's sub rural
yeah this isn't LA you can I'm no I'm
not I know I'm just that sewer lay
yourself Holly livin hot you guys were
like oh they live in a house but look at
this city Anne has 12 million followers
on Instagram dude yeah he's huge this is
from six hours ago Wow I was like one of
the first people oh wow
no he's super huge in Turkey and let me
tell you what he's national treasure
it's not like the biggest like
international Turkish celebrity well
salt Bay he's passed even salt-based
somehow and now he's catering to the
English fans he says the greatest bond
is love no I think I had an influence in
that because I kept saying where's the
English in the descriptions mm-hmm and
now we get English news we need
subtitles next that's true actually
actually I would love subtitles and
ultimately I think we need to go to
Turkey and you can go to his a
restaurant I really want to try an
entire lamb stuffed with lamb stuffed
with lettuce and cabbage whatever this
guy goes crazy but it actually turns out
that this guy's mobility scooter is
probably the nicest car in town anyway
good feel good feel good everybody what
you gonna say something bad about me no
I was gonna say he actually seems like a
nice guy he's a sweetheart he's all the
smiles and as he said here the greatest
bond is love as you know as you well
know either you know that better than
anyone
all the smiles dealt me suspicious yeah
you know well that one video he made
where he
isn't smiling that was maybe that was
pretty through season and by the way
he's wearing like a cashmere sweater I
mean he's kind of doing a hard
aggressive flux on these guys out in the
village like he rolls up with mobility
scooter what can a cashmere sweater you
know I mean he's all this [ __ ] like why
is he so tall he's towering over them
even his height is a flex on them like
if you're that wide everyone's so short
in that town dude he doesn't fit in
there archway do you know what I mean
you've got it all going on if he's so
tall why he shouldn't be allowed in that
city yeah why is he have it all going on
anyway I'm fascinated I continue to be
fascinated by caesium and we give it up
to our one true Turkish got our friend
over a turkey seasons and Borak from Al
Sun Libra get him pronounce that EULA ah
ah cut girl Senora go ahead yeah that's
true that's is quite literally true more
scooter related content I know you guys
can't get enough that you guys just
gotta trust me when I curate scooter
content that it's good
I see people complaining oh the podcast
went downhill since they started talking
about scooters who said that nobody said
that I think I read a cop I mean comment
but but do you I mean genuinely I mean
the scooter stuffs great right yeah yeah
I know sometimes we hear what the
audience is sometimes people so doubt in
my mind and I'm like I thought the
Gatsby was funny and you know like watch
this video you just gotta trust me I'm
getting more particularly you have to
raise the stakes
you trust me watch this you're gonna
believe me need to regulate scooters on
the street okay because I guess the
as you as you see here in America people
in scooters are very crazy you know I
don't know if she's pro or for scooter
uh protection or speed limits but off
she goes on her scooter and she tipped
like a car video am I wrong good you see
you gotta trust you work hard this
content you can't get just comments a
complaint I worked all day non-stop
generating content okay we have a full
team of professionals to bring you
videos like that Dan Ian worked
tirelessly right it's not a mobility but
you know what I was thinking when I said
to the genre I started seeing videos of
these and then I think to myself well
that's not a scooter but then I say well
what do you call it it's quick it's a
scooter right it's not a mobility
scooter mobility scooter and Zack - Zack
is here Zack is a he doesn't help us
with the research but he's here on the
sound bytes
Zack is a freelancer because he goes to
school like a good sweet lad just a
little background Zack I wanted to give
him props but he's the best
isn't that right Zack much now go much
love much love does that smile I
actually do really want to give it up to
the guys backstage before we move on
Danny I want to give it up yeah Dan yeah
give that yesterday yeah look at that
smile come on give it up how's this
installed the most difficult
installation of a printer ever in its
history over at Eddie fresh off your
camera looks especially screwed today
Dan people have been demanding upgrades
you got to let me buy but I don't
prohibit you from buying what I would
lastly when have I ever told you not to
buy I want like an RT Alexa back here I
want like a $50,000 I am let's see it
yeah let's see that baby
honestly that printer installation you
get any light you want you don't be
funny if we could have two cameras back
there one that's like Lois possible like
120 P and then like four K so you could
split depending on the resolution you
want to be yep okay arrange that and Ian
of course I mean the silent assassin he
does read a and I credit today for
finding one of my favorite stories in a
long time methanol on a joints Instagram
but yeah Ian does so much for us he's
the highlight god he's the thumbnail god
he's the the life switcher
he's the getter these guys man they went
through a lot just to get those gummy
hamburgers yesterday and I'm telling you
it's gonna be worth it you have a lot of
preciate you my heart for him I
appreciate that
in fact you've got so much better at
doing the sound bites to it's just
really become a fun part of the show
thank you coming to your own there thank
you thank you
cool let's do dinner
appreciation day yeah let's go yeah it
is appreciation day and now that that's
out of the way Trisha got married you
want to do this hurry let's just do it
really quick because it's kind of a 1:1
tone thing like
I mean some explain this to me there's
no witness II what's the joke well I'll
tell you that's a good question
their audio is on the channel also real
to add to the disaster anybody what's
gone headphones apologize
I mean she's clearly just trying to make
content because as you can see you got
hurt chuckling me pause this this all
wedding content right like I'm getting
married
calling my ex to tell them I'm getting
married what I wore the wedding night
and then the official wedding thing so
it's all part of this you know oh and
then a week ago she said I spent five
hundred on her bread pitcher and now
she's wearing the Brad Pitt cut out a
lot of the comments were like I think
Brad Pitt probably saw this and got a
restraining order which is funny and
probably true so I think it's just a
content thing I'm assuming that's her
mom on the left looking fabulous and
Trisha of course she wear the same boots
to our podcast yeah that's a versatile
shoe if you wear to our podcast and your
own wedding now how would you consider
would you consider that wedding attire
he led the Trish's wearing
that's a tricia wedding attire yeah but
she did it right I mean the makeup and
the hair she went all out yeah so what
you have is a life-size cutout of Brad
Pitt with a flower arrangement pinned on
his it's quite quiet isn't it yeah we
turned down the baby the wedding is I
believe that I'm not free you can't
copyright love there's no behind Brad
Pitt what are they doing
I think I saw in the comments that it's
her sister hiding behind there why why
any of this what's going on holding them
up I can't believe that she involved her
family and oh it they didn't even get
like the pistol keep it standing
but I don't see him moving because it
would be bobbing if she was holding it
she's got photography yeah she I think
that this is all comes with the package
they're in like Vegas
well is it no what saying anything I
can't hear anything well I want to hear
what they're saying
for Christ's sake okay can turn the
sound off there's not much to see she
says oh she has she gives her vows
listen to her vows here we go so I hear
jazz Diddy in the background you think
that's some Kenny G [ __ ] it might be
it's well it's in her video so she she
you know what I mean she's trying to get
a penny off this and we know we know she
is yeah I happen to actually know that
we know yeah let's take a chance let's
take a chance on love I'm just gonna do
this just so we don't get claimed the
whole time
[Music]
okay that's it I don't wanna play to the
jazz but she want is it a statement on
men someone who wouldn't judge me if she
says someone wouldn't leave me won't be
back to me won't say I'm weird yeah I
mean is that a statement mean I mean I
won't talk back to me well sometimes you
have and when you have an equal partner
so I'm talking back is required right
that's the back and forth you're looking
for a partner or subservient being right
and judgment is certainly important as
well because let's just be frank I mean
some of our more base instincts need to
be need to be fished back to civility
because I don't know I'm just saying I
mean treasure your lot to handle
you gotta cut through ever your with
some slack man yeah yeah anyway I don't
know where to go with this book though
everyone was oh yeah she's totally
holding him yeah her sisters just
holding Brad Pitt cool yeah yeah she's
just holding him figure out there's a
camp and this is epic I wonder if feel
like consummated the relationship she
probably put last the next video goes up
on pornhub I can see a way for her to do
that I mean oh God
so they're both grabbing a candle the
sister is definitely holding a Brad Pitt
she's grabbing the candle because he
can't obviously he's a cardboard cutout
mom is smiling in the background they're
both lighting the candle sister almost
touched the flame she can't put the
flame out she's shaking violently okay
she got it but what is she thinking I
mean this isn't even like funny that I
would dare you by the way she's not a
troll remember
or she is a lot of back and forth um can
you really copy claim like a jet like a
saxophone spine by Kenny G like oh it
does have its own stand you guys I'm
happy yeah okay and sister said and her
family is pretty down for anything
so congratulations Wow
hopefully he likes being egg
[Music]
I don't think Brad is gay but apparently
that's not a problem for you because you
can be both gay and lesbian at the same
time whatever that means congratulations
to Trisha Paytas she's found true love
Wow Brad Pitt the cutout of Brad Pitt
and congratulations to press its lawyer
who just got another 20 billable hours
to file a restraining order all in all
it's a it's a positive turn out meme now
this is something I like doing on the
beginning of the week today is Tuesday's
that radio that is right is right thank
you for confirming I like to take a look
back at the spiciest memes of the
subreddit see what you guys get in the
brains and the minds of our beautiful
fans our worshippers if you would say
that is that too much you let to call
them worshippers yes
well what are they then people me
patiently waiting for a tree production
to upload what is this meme format it's
hilarious what and what's with the are
you familiar with the origin story of
this with the family guy in the
wheelchair and the pack I I've seen it
everyone peanut M&Ms are better those
are eight here Allah P Eminem is Eminem
right here's this story I don't know
what boy boy means but it says why boy
could someone clue me on oh boy boy boy
boy a collision between two
grandmother's has prompted calls for an
indoor speed limit for mobility scooters
a judge has recommended they be
restricted to just 3 km/h whoa boy boy
is a is a town in Australia
why boy Australians man they don't give
a [ __ ] they're calling their towns boy
boy that crazy as it gets
yep that's awesome I love I love it
Kido does not work for this bear so Zoo
tries new feeding window yeah
there you have it
we'll keep you updated on that National
Geographic exclusive and then just
generally giving it up for ian's costume
that I guess maybe you know it's just it
was fantastic so round of applause to
our boys I got a piece so bad
eats a bagel once two seconds later
shuttle home everybody I mean bagel okay
you know now this is a meme format in
and tell me if this violates our
contract but I'm gonna read it in Ex
Australian girl oh yeah hold on
well I didn't write this there's just a
meme for my I think the contracts pretty
clear on this yeah
I'm not probing him for more information
I'm just reading the meme I can read a
ring like all mention no no no no I can
reference that it happen I cannot probe
deeper that's the Sun right now anything
who made you the I'm just looking out
worried he was gonna get sued
well ela was the I mean when did you
were the third party you you're the
notary to this deal I was a witness like
you don't know if there was a mention
about memes we said we can reference
that it happen but we cannot probe
deeper right ela what is your ruling
it's a name that references the avais
meanness is approved thank you
yeah any objection do you want to dance
come to take the contract I think he's
my lawyer now whoa hold on okay so do
you guys want to appeal this to a higher
court he's overlooking the information
I'm reviewing right now hold on okay
well in the meantime I'm gonna read this
Mimi it's actually not about the mystery
more about the RV's it's this Vince
McMahon thing it goes in times X
Australian girl he's interested in X mr.
EDM girl
he's orgasming be an ex Arby's
drive-thru guy
fully engaged yeah then I mean Ian said
he would allow it so what are you gonna
do but as you're tested by the letter of
the law I would say that that that
that's skirted it pretty close here all
right nice so sue me literally look we
got it we have to take these these are
legal matters that need to be
adjudicated in the proper Court and I
think ela I mean look we're in her
district and she rolled it if you want
to appeal it to a higher court to the
applet a eppela core appellate appellate
court I don't know who is above ela I
think me I think I want to feel it to me
we can do that I have a constitutional
crisis on why this is funny I thought
you guys would enjoy this wine and candy
pairing cotton which is just insane to
begin with but the goof is you've got
all these candies and then the candy
corn just goes in the garbage more that
you means which shouldn't we expected
Shalom everybody Shalom to you Zach
morphing in the broth cell Ian looking
like a little like this dot little dog
so that's funny
this girl dressed as me and hot as a
girl dresses me like old school me and
really good pretty killer [ __ ] me
explained that I'm saving the world by
planting trees my mom with a ten
thousand knowledge charge on her bank
account I really like this because I
feel like that probably happened a
couple of times but that facio me it's
like how to attract r.kelly b-minor it's
someone playing B minor on the guitar
you could also do a minor to a minor how
to check our Kelly a minor I like B
minor better me enjoying my dinner
watching a street podcast if all the
fissures oh man this next one one by the
way just I'm a personal note I don't
have that trouble I can eat and listen
yeah maybe I'm just not sensitive to
that yeah but what can I do you know
this one made me laugh so hard for all
it was just called revenge so they took
the black they put on the black they had
all these huge black guys in the tiny
girl do they turned all the huge black
guys white and put the girl's face
they're so good and then they made the
little girl black and put one the plan
oh it just it looks amazing oh yeah this
is really talent because they changed
the skin color incredible would you
watch that this looks like a horror
movie
mmm Bella I mean uh Trisha probably into
that just because the genders all over
the place do you remember Julia people
were goofing on me for the George
Washington do you remember when George
Washington heard that the air planes hit
the World Trade Center what are you
talking now this is a meme that nobody
can relate to because nobody listens
that piece first 40 minutes
of the podcast versus the last 45
minutes of the podcast according to you
what's the connection
according to me yes I feel like we
should do this at the end this kind of
dull you know it's like more of an
ending segment cuz it's like yeah take
your time I'm actually eating candy
right now that's exciting anyway this is
them telling George Washington mmm candy
corn that's it let's get out of here
awful I should done that then nobody
well it's break time so let's do that so
okay thank God when we come back we're
got the best stuff I mean it just gets
outrageous from here this Matthew
McConaughey thing the candy revue it's
just going to get better and better and
better
a lot of dudes are losing their hair
it's the year almost 2020 that sounds
futuristic because it is futuristic we
need to keep that beautiful hair on your
head where it belongs so that a cooties
can run their hands through your hair
and find out what the head of a real man
feels like not humiliating and I just
was kidding
real men are also bald for example Lex
Luthor is a masculine man that doesn't
have hair by his own choice so it's a
good luck either way but if you want to
keep your hair hims is the way to do it
because you want to save the hair before
you start to lose it that's why you got
to go to four hands calm the
one-stop-shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men thanks to
science baldness can be optional hims is
helping guys be the best version of
themselves with a licensed physicians
and fda approved products to help treat
hair loss this is the real deal folks
prescription solutions that are backed
by science hims was created by a guy who
knows some men's health conversations
are easier online than in person there's
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or along pharmacy waits for hims
connects you with real doctors online
which could save you hours and hundreds
of dollars completely confidential and
discreet I mean it's no secret that
you're balding though to be honest
answer a few quick questions it depends
how you do your hair I guess answer a
few quick questions or if you are a hat
answer a few quick questions a doctor
will review and if they terminus right
for you can prescribe you medicine to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your dang door this Thanksgiving when
all the relatives say healthy in full
they'll finally be talking about your
hair and not the turkey wow your turkey
order right now my listeners get started
with hims complete hair loss kit for
just five dollars today right now while
supplies last and subject to doctor's
approval see the website for full
details and safety information this
could cost hundreds if you went to the
doctor or pharmacy somewhere else so go
to for hemes dot-com / HP that's fo r h
IM
dot-com / h-34 hems calm /h 3
the problem here's the solution you're
fat like me and you want to be skinny
and beautiful like ela that's where noon
comes in noon and it's not just about
being fat or being skinnier B it's
nothing healthy as well make the right
change our habits about make the right
thing it's about having a healthy
relationship with food it's about living
a healthy lifestyle not rob to hate
yourself every day and you make being
you eating awful things you just full
regret every time you have a meal that's
what neumes about neumes about getting
in shape losing weight learning
healthier habits etc etc it's an app
okay you track your calories but that's
not all you're part of a community
you've got a trainer that motivates you
and talks to you and keeps you on
schedule but here's what's interesting
you got to learn that not all foods are
just good and bad there's no such thing
as bad and good foods it's all about
moderation it's all about ratio so when
you're eating foods this apps gonna tell
you this is a good food you're gonna
want to eat a lot of this this is a bad
food you can have some of this but not
too much when I'm using this app I
learned a lot the food that I thought
was ok was actually really bad like I
would have liked a bowl of frosted
mini-wheats
and maybe I'm just an idiot but they're
like a red bad food I was like [ __ ] I
had like 2,000 colors of frosted many
ways today but that's what I'm saying
you learn this stuff through this app
it's educational and it's oh they
there's a lot of literature they give
you they have this whole regiment it's
really unlike anything else it's based
on psychology they teach you why you do
the things you do and they give you the
tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with better ones it's not a
diet again it's easy to stick to way of
life they're a habit changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses Noom is working for
people it's helping people that were not
finding the way to get it through to
them because it's educating them it's
changing their habits
it's just noon ya got it check it out
you don't have to change it all in one
day either small steps make big Prague
that's what it's all about over at noon
sign up for your trial today at n 0 m
dot com / H true that's noon what do you
have to lose head on over to Noom comm /
H for you to get your trial started
today that's Noom dot-com / h3 the last
weight loss program you'll ever need and
now let's eat a bunch of candy
welcome back it is your one true leader
into the next life and beyond by
watching this you agree to the terms of
my agreement that you will be my humble
worshipper for the next billion years
and by watching this you agree to this
that's a sign tells you does they go by
entering they make you enter a
billion-year contract for your soul it's
like why not 2 billion 1 billion years
then you're off the hook
how much brainwashing is there to get
someone to sign that like how do you
hear that and you're like okay sure
you're like a billion mmm about how
about how about five hundred million
guys yeah yeah there's a couple of
honorable mentions that you guys should
see in the meme section of this show
these ones are good and I'm sorry to say
again it's mobility related but that
they're all good that they're doing I
just gotta trust me
like here's some idiot trying to go down
an escalator in a wheelchair and you
just this lady passed by the grace of
God also why are you going backwards
like you were literally just asking it
died those things are hard man doesn't
that's on the escalator you know it's
one of my greatest fears is being on the
ground where the escalator goes
underground where the teeth hey I feel
like you will I feel like even if my
shoe gets stuck like a little bit I
don't step right I'm gonna get sucked
underneath and ground into minced meat
don't you feel that I don't but I could
see that's like a horror movie it looks
like one of those it looks like that
that's what would happen I mean and so
well he didn't get that didn't happen to
him but oh this is the best you guys
dude this is the best ever you guys take
this advice to heart people
because okay torch the torches you get
them let you know okay if you touch the
torches you get down this one okay you
don't have anymore
what you do you take one of these now
this is going to help you save on your
toilet tissue he's holding one square
gel around you fold it one time you fold
it two times then you fold a third time
okay then you see there's a boat tip
right here you turn that off
if you sit on the stool you put it
beside the student once you get done
taking this [ __ ] or pissing you put your
friend in there you white guys okay then
you take this and you might follow this
off why wait okay all that [ __ ] then you
take this you put it in the stove or
flush it so my question to you is do you
think he's goofing or is this something
he's done I'm afraid he's not goofing
I'm afraid he's done this book because
the way he like showed how to do it it's
like he was experienced in that motion
yeah and like he gotta do the nail with
the tip so next time you shake hands of
anyone in public I thought about that
too you wonder like what did they do
with their hands just a minute ago I
mean you should be wary I was in again
I'm having all these horror stories in
our bathroom but there was somebody in
there taking a crap he was on the phone
he walked out and he literally after
[ __ ] he just he squirted the water
on and off on his hands he just watched
no so he grabbed the towel didn't even a
dry he's just Shh I'm like you know this
is what people are doing out there their
hands are covered in [ __ ]
just say my this guy's shoving his
finger up his ass to wipe and I mean
with once where it's all paper to speak
up but I'll tell you what gives the
credibility that it's not a joke
the way he's tucked in there with the
wife beater what do you guys think is
this real or or a joke it's pretty
authentic but I don't know hard to say I
get to see this is the part that either
thing look at look at him go
that looks like experience look at it
though he does say this is like this is
an emergency procedure though if you're
at a toilet pit right
you know what that's that that's
preferable yes yes dude you cannot get
[ __ ] out of your fingernail like you'll
you will have that shut and your
fingernail for like a month
do you know like sometimes you get like
if you eat flaming hot cheetos your
fingernails be red for like a year
yeah right [ __ ] is even crazier in there
and good luck getting the smell off wait
okay yeah forget about that this is
awful that's like some prison [ __ ] I
feel like I mean maybe yeah good bye
Miyo useful tutorial for some perhaps I
just loved a little nail wipe at the end
he's like then you wipe under the nail
and you're good to shake hands so that
was a great one and then this one
cracked me up this was from the LSD
subreddit these are some instace stories
I've been doing there's like a filter
where as you you could see it just to
make Alice T sub-2 that one nose
cross-posted okay they said according to
my sitter I spent 20 minutes staring at
this image without saying anything but
giggling every once in a while and
showing it to them over and over and
over
this is terrifying but there's this
filter on Instagram work it makes it
look like there's a thousand of you it's
I think it's hilarious
they only heated two so happy that I
could participate in your trip hell yeah
what doesn't mean according to my sitter
so I guess responsible users have some
leftover watch them yeah yeah took me a
minute okay now let's get to the red
meat Matthew McConaughey joins Instagram
and you know how we feel about Garth
Brooks joining Facebook back in the day
the vibes between McConaughey and Garth
Brooks like if you make an announcement
that you joining Instagram there's
already like so much to make fun of
right there right
why are you announcing it you know I
think what inspired him was that
Jennifer Aniston
joined Instagram and she was not on
social media and a lot of people were
excited she got like 5 million followers
in a day or something crazy and so I
think Matthew thought to himself well
I'm a I'm a big movie star and I'm an
interesting guy so I'm gonna do that too
and the thing is when I look back at
Garth's video I mean it's in a square
it's like four by four I mean this was a
different age this was like the I'm
serious I have got it here it was a long
time ago and so his whole thing of like
I like that I'm joining Facebook was was
more understandable but you really can't
take that vibe today on Instagram and
Twitter which is the Matthew McConaughey
is really the Garth Brooks of the 22nd
century so here we go so the
announcement that he's joining Instagram
starts with an announcement on Twitter
so we're gonna start there the story has
a lot of chapters so here's chapter 1 he
says he says officially McConaughey here
we go baby
there we go
born November the 4th 1969 got my dad's
name the very same day but not until I
turned 50 today you got become
officially happy that's my Instagram
handle see you there so again it's like
these guys why is he trying so they just
don't get it that's not you're not here
to do monologues in like haiku it's not
like yeah there's nothing authentic
about that it's like shot on a stab you
lights like stabilized it's he's done
that I guarantee he did that shot like
20 times
also there's like some slick editing at
the end which I guarantee this guy
doesn't know how to edit so he's paying
someone you know to edit this and
actually I don't understand what he's
saying either what what does turning 50
have to do it of now officially becoming
McConaughey I think he just made a rhyme
you don't think it means anything you
think he's just trying to rhyme I think
you say that about him that's what I
underst let's break this down
oh yeah cuz he join Instagram when his
50th birthday oh that's just the name of
his that's the name of his handle it's
not anything like deep about like yeah
so today on his 50th birthday he became
a fish on a hey hey hey you the one you
come here often so so he's made he's
made the announcement on Twitter so we
gotta go over his Twitter falls over to
Instagram I feel like he wants to be in
competition with Jennifer Aniston I
think he was jealous or he that she got
so much attention for that big joint
Instagram he's not getting the same
reception that she got and by the way
what she posted
was a picture of her with all of the
friends cast so it was like a big it was
that that's a great social post oh yeah
this is some weird [ __ ] you know what I
mean do you have that what the yeah yeah
it's so funny that this guy is like
joining Instagram is a story that the
news report about no like I saw her on
Jimmy Kimmel active talking about it
yeah look this was her first picture by
the way some shitty like no light selfie
you know what I mean that's what social
media is all about 15,000,000 like
exactly do you know I mean Matthew
McConaughey if you're watching this and
I know you are yeah I'm kidding
obviously you know about the whole
controversy with this picture what the
people pointed out look at the phone on
the counter kind of looks like there's a
some racks of coke oh okay but why would
you maybe the phone is like the most
disgusting thing but there you have it
people do it but there's like a mirror
next to it yeah and people rightly point
out it very well could just be a
reflection and probably is Blair it's
just glare from the light you know what
happened they're like you know what we
need to do for all the time say and by
the way what's this guy's name who
played Chandler Luke Perry or some
cheesy all right come on I know I don't
know this stuff just tell me his name
again a Matthew
he's like a mess he got photographed he
has a drug problem he has it he's
addicted I mean he was very good I just
stopped doing a lot of drugs to make
sure of him what's his name Matthew
Perry yes Matthew Perry Elley look at
this picture I just saw him this okay
look at this photo
dude you're gonna tell me how slick he
looks look at this bro this is from like
last night to be fair I couldn't see a
picture of you like that yeah that's how
I usually look that's not a good day for
me
[Laughter]
apparently he was in rehab and all this
soap huh just see they say friends star
Matthew Perry looks disheveled
I hate and rare thought oh I know what
am i doing I'm feeding it's a yeah look
at these photos are so funny I'm off
tonight looks like he's being rejected
on top of it it's just crazy how he
transformed from like Chandler to
needing a handler that song that's like
a Matthew McConaughey line anyway anyway
I guess my point is that I can see him
showing up with like with some blow sure
it's right in front of him and I bet you
everyone else was like uh dude come on
like I mean this does this we have kids
and [ __ ] but he see he did it it's for
him what Dan I I was agreeing with you
it is it is in front of him so yeah
thank you that is so epic but anyway
that's beside the point
the point is that this is a great social
post amazing so how many followers this
you have so now she's all about she's
mrs. Instagram 18 million what in God's
name
when dough ended she started like it
just - it's like a wish you have like
one two she has like eight posts can you
see when was it posted this was posted
and I was like two weeks ago three weeks
ago
yeah but I swell I'm saying that is a
great whoa this is 25 million views oh
this is just an ad for a movie or
something mmm I can't get it - all right
but the point is that you know I mean
compared to this that's my it's such a
Garth Brooks fallacy there's got to be
like a psychological diagnosis of what
this is it's the Garth Brooks syndrome
so that's the announcement now here
we're going to the Instagram video that
was the announcement for the
announcement was it the announcement for
the announcement that was the
announcement here now here's the real
the actual announcement right that's
right it was an announcement for the
announcement on Instagram now this is
the video there - I'm just gonna play it
okay I want to see see me look this is
my first venture into sharing myself and
my views with the world and I'm a little
bit nervous about it because quite
frankly I'm like I know I won't have a
monologue I'm not sure when I have the
dialogue but I've learned that you got a
dialogue that's made have the monologue
doesn't really get do that I'll break
the dialogue so I'm looking forward to
it I'm looking forward to sharing Who I
am with you I'm looking forward to
seeing it for if Who I am translates if
what I want to share translate doesn't
do funny it makes you think a second
makes your heart swell up a little bit
if it makes you take a quiet moment for
a while and go I gotta check in with em
and hopefully all those things let's
have some fun with it though and let's
again let's keep the high and low aye
aye aye
like it's crazy it's like the same baby
Wow now let me break it down here pretty
little bit more you can see how
unnatural it is so again it's the same
thing as Garth Brooks wears like it's
just me
Rami yeah and and and so this video has
a lot of cuts in it and a lot of
crossfades on the audio to try to hide
the cuts and so and and what's with the
the font to like it says on the bottom
somebody put a subtitle it says I want
them to see me look this is my first
it's also got a filter too right
sure shred are you ruining Matthew
McConaughey's moment shreddy you're
ruining the moment love you though
because quite frankly I'm like I know I
won't have a monologue I'm not sure I
won't have the dialogue that [ __ ] was
dude he laughed so hard at that bro it
made me uncomfortable and like he's not
looking at the camera he's looking at
that's the only time you look at the
camera Ross fade and now he which is so
awful I cannot stand when there's a fade
like if you're just recording yourself
and making a cut and then you do a fade
it makes it so weird ticked right on the
audio and audio yeah just do the hard
cut I mean yeah I mean I really think
that's about but I've learned that yes I
have the dialogue well you know why they
do it is because probably the audio cut
is just so like yeah heard that yeah but
he's trying to make it seem like like I
could see him in the editing room with
his editor being like you know do the
fade a little further further okay you
can't tell it's cut right you know what
I mean
learned that you gotta have the dialogue
to have the monologue just as you have
to have a mom do that is it just all
those people face well looking forward
to it like artists people just sold and
they like trying social media and they
kind of like missed the mark I don't
know what he expects from it it's not
what you think
good I think you might be right just
boomer town boomer boomer Graham this is
boomer Graham boomer is a derogatory
term against Pope but we'll get into
that later but no no Sharon who I am
with you I'm looking forward to seeing
it for God I am translates is what I
want to share translates when he starts
to get deep here yeah rope what are you
gonna tell me this is gonna make my
heart swell up on Instagram also is this
how he talks
cuz I thought that's like nobody talks
like this that's what so I know nothing
he thinks it's a movie yeah is she
taking quiet moment for a walk oh I
gotta check in with M&E hopefully all
those things are you single essentially
no and this house again let's keep the
high low I what is the higher I think
you must be single you only a single man
can make a video that that did Tash from
reality check
yeah that's my prediction Matthew
McConaughey wife oh damn hold on he's
married to some young Brazilian he's got
three kids these kids need to help him
out he should have passed by them is he
married or single children three spouse
married and oh he's married to some
young models
I think Zack would find her very
attractive she's right
why am i why are you just making why am
i slandering him I saw a picture of her
I knew she looked like she was very
young
this is what I saw smaller
so why is nobody tell is nobody helping
him he's got three kids he's got a young
I mean a younger young wife just a
little older than us why is nobody
interfering with this somebody needs to
step in quickly
I think his kids are too young to know
maybe you're right
damn well anyway it continues on
continues on he's now doing Instagram
stories oh by the way on his I thought
this was funny on his Instagram post
Lincoln left the comment our favorite
let me see if I can find it because it's
kind of hard to when I should go it on
my phone it just shows me like big
accounts that commented and Lincoln said
enjoy the ride
and then they put - Lincoln [ __ ] epic
so here's this Instagram story again
notice okay this is like a high quality
product it's on like a damn boys I may
not be willing but capably able do i
have an instagram i'll be like 'ooh
everybody
but guess what it is now a lot cooler
cuz I did I did scram let's do this dude
that is let's get some Howdy's Go Daddy
that is such a garden howdy we got a
sound bite though let's get some Howdy's
going like that it's like so here's what
I've done now to celebrate Matthews
transcen Shinto Boomer gram I what I've
what I've done is I've I've put together
his video announcing he's out on
Instagram and Garth Brooks original
video announcing he's on Facebook and I
think that for whatever reason there is
some scientific value to watching these
videos at the same time together I think
that there's I think we're gonna like
this kind of this kind of announcement
joining to Instagram also will end up
the same as Garth Brooks where you'll
never post again I think you're right
cuz all he can talk about is like
alright I'm on Instagram he doesn't know
that I actually did just be himself it's
a whole production any probably I don't
like five people yeah shooting and
editors steadicams
lighting let's see if you post anything
else before we buried in it oh you saw
yeah bro that's you're already messing
up we need content already anyway here
we go here's the combination
check in with hopefully all those things
let's have some fun with it though
unless that's again let's keep the hi I
blow I hi I
what does that mean everybody knows what
that what does it mean so there you have
it I felt not below honey hi I I think
what he's if I had to guess and it's a
stretch it's a deep stretch like the
third eye I maybe like that we got to
keep it like positive I know what he
means is I look at the bright side like
look at the half full cup not the half
am i high I not the low I hmm
does anyone have an idea back there is
it talking about people that have one I
keep your keep your head up you know
keep the high so we're looking up lazy
eyes together you free well at the end
of the video it looks like he's like
that we joint yeah exactly yeah but he
is a notorious smoker right I hate to
say it the master butters okay cause
them idea what's that player in the
bottom
maybe I didn't understand this I still I
mean even Garth cars did it better than
I want to see 6th anyway so there you go
math welcome everybody welcome Adam
Akane to the welcome to the Internet
give him the meme treatment let's see
shoenice called us out Kela if you can
give that actually this feels pretty
good as I make it as I call now I'm
telling you guys shoenice would be an
incredible guest on this podcast ok but
and I really truly think she nice would
be an amazing guest ok but I'm scared of
him I mean I genuinely don't feel safe
with him he's huge he's unhinged and
he's not huge no he's a big strong guy
regular no he's a strong guy dude he
showed one where he was getting all
jacked like trying to get ready for
about he [ __ ] kill me I can protect
you from him dude he would go he's got
this deadness in his eyes he would kill
everybody in this office before you
could even get to the exit I'm telling
you so we would need some kind of
security I'm serious I wouldn't I want
security wouldn't you Dan I'm not as
threatened by him but then again I'm you
know he's he's probably more mad at you
than he is it I don't think he's mad I
just think he's like the Joker he's like
he's a nihilist he's just he's not mad I
mean he just he's unpredictable do you
know what I mean you put on like Joker
makeup and whatever yeah so anyway here
he Mook bangs I don't even know if you
can call it a Mook pain
just slams two giant sausages and calls
me out well basically No Shave November
everybody knows that's easy
no not November's are oh my god dancing
oh god dude imagine that without the
writing on the back so can we just keep
playing more videos together I just want
to add that note to the Guardian it
actually takes some work though you have
to like think um I had this pinnacle of
my thing but I think that would be an
interesting segment to explore like how
videos synergize so here he's slamming
to giant cow bosses growth honestly I
mean it is kind of impressive but mostly
just looks like he's eating lunch really
fast you know you mean I mean you don't
need much slower than that you're about
as noisy I guess maybe we should have a
Mook bangle he's here
also his thing as he doesn't believe the
heel will go 20 minutes blinking hey
does have a beautiful blue eyes love the
sound you don't need to talk to you now
as a great one since we said that no you
he doesn't blink it's this thing now I'm
blinking the composition I like can't
stop blinking now this is a good podcast
people help me Ethan okay when I meet
them on the street that quality content
and I say well I stand on the shoulder
of the giants before me
and this is what I mean this is what I'm
talking about when I say that look oh
that's looks like he's stroking out time
baby I don't think anyone was keeping I
thumbed it up you know granted people
without water
everybody's got their hero on YouTube I
don't need to mention names they take
the water out of Nathan's Hot Dogs Joey
Chestnut Mass Tony just I wasn't gonna
mention anybody sue me
he's calling up the other eaters are
using water like [ __ ] million
subscriber I'm too cool to help anybody
in the pool it's oh did he mention me
when we missed it dan is quite an intern
about manners yeah no mom I brought here
camo bro everybody gets the million he
already slammed me granted people I do
my stunts without water everybody's got
to mention names when they take the
water out of Nathan's Hot Dogs Joey
Chestnut Mass Tony just I wasn't gonna
mention anybody sue me no many people I
brought to your camo bro
everybody gets the million subscriber
I'm too cool to help literally a joke or
monologue it's sad
I can't wait till I have like five ten
million subscribers like h3h Street I
won't make videos just call another
youtubers crazy I'll actually support
them and put them on the show any
promises them
I got your goof gang brah I mean eat
didn't feel really good people what a
great family I'm gonna visit them they
don't even know I'm coming I see that's
what I'm saying was you know put on this
picture no having heard that he's coming
to visit us and we don't even know he's
coming you don't like the sound of that
at all shoenice here this is the who
shows up at your front door or is it
there's a nice one with the writing and
her just makes everything look a
trillion times more psycho so I think if
you want to have them it's gotta be off
site off site it's gonna be somewhere in
the public oh that's not good it's got
to be in the podcast studio how we need
to we need a hand that we needed
security
I want to handcuff him while he's in
here they don't use the handcuffs to
like choke me out you know what I mean
he literally and I'm thinking so really
is very unpredictable that's what I'm
saying like you know in minehunters that
at that he cozies up to that serial
killer and then at the end he scares the
[ __ ] out of him yeah that's what I
imagined true nice doing he like goes in
for a hug that's too long yeah and like
starts to scare the [ __ ] that right
exactly because he's the Joker in real
life he's just like the Mook bang
version of the Joker
dude why you gotta say all that creepy
[ __ ] like I didn't expect that
shoenice trying to have you on my show
you know and now you're threatening to
come to my house unannounced but you
were the one who found this video yeah
didn't watch the last five didn't watch
the last five seconds whoops
shoenice
well whatever don't come to my house
please let's have a podcast instead now
Ethan Bradberry regular 102 he's really
stepping it up man I'm proud of what
Ethan is made of the regular I wish he
could turn this into like a coffee book
or you know coffee table book or
something cuz he's really put together a
a real catalog of content and what I'm
seeing here is a real evolution of it as
you see he's got his whole gang in the
back more importantly he's upgraded
though dude they're all posing like a
boyband he got all of his homies in on
this isn't that crazy
what number I know at one point I've
seen the gangbang I have to say that I'm
not impressed with this poor usually
it's like a perfect cup he's not used to
this this steel dome at all and I I said
to him Ethan to be frank I don't know
how I feel about the metal pot because I
kind of liked the charm that he's always
breaking the glass right he says I don't
like it one bit so maybe so temporary
yeah he was trying to do oh it's trying
and that's nice push the envelope you
know when Bob Dylan started playing
electric guitar it was this is a very
similar situation
Judas Judas and then before we get into
the candy tier list I do want to get
your take on this
oh it's deleted come on how could
that's it what was it this the cup I'll
find a new one it was the couple eating
cooked caught eating mayonnaise it was
sent to me ten thousand okay good so
either you wake up in the middle of the
night and this is over your bed what are
you doing oh my god either way either
way I'm Nick
oh you'll die today either way did you
send it to me somehow they scrub the
Internet of this couple eating
mayonnaise at a hockey game they must be
really high connected under the
reuploading Daily Mail of all places
there you go so tell me if you think
this is real cuz I have a suspicion that
they're cool I think it's stage there's
clowning well why would they take it
down you know I mean like Hershey just
taken a big-ass bite at Hellman and
homies dipping his fry in it what you
know is gross but like you can kind
under you're using as a condom ya know
the fry makes sense but she's just
scooping she's going I think that's got
to be a gag maybe they're fans of the
show yeah they're well they were trying
to get caught I mean she's got like the
biggest jar of mayonnaise that you can
find right it's a guy anymore watch that
it's obviously a gag now I mean I can't
wait to eat this [ __ ] candy we've got
the bell Delphine we've got the butt
let's do that after and the Boomer stuff
but let's get to this candy right before
it expires or do with you the candy last
I want the candy right now let's get
this tearless open we got a lot of good
content oh don't go away all right I
mean seriously here we go continuing
anything you want them to comment to
flatter you and then you're gonna forget
oh yes a if you guys watch too this far
I mean this is pretty early in the show
there's when people start falling off
but if you are at this point you want to
leave a comment let me know say Ethan is
super funny and
looks like you lost a ton away and huge
fans of the show keep it up you thin so
here we go this is the big names ok
there's so much candy here I don't know
how we're gonna do it all but let's go
let's go yeah we got a slam through
these there's third let's just buy it
right off the bat okay good stuff here
not wasting any time okay peanut butter
M&Ms there was there was a debate if
M&Ms are separate from peanut butter and
I think they are yes okay that's what
everyone thinks the panelling now these
ones you can make argument like pretzel
and that I don't care about whatever no
that's [ __ ] those are gimmicks
there's peanuts M&Ms and there's M&Ms
that being said everybody takes the
milligrams peanut mmm okay
I'm gonna try so hard not to smack my
lips I'm so are okay if you want my
honest opinion peanut butter on them s
yeah this is the best oh my god its
holder v peanut butter or peanut peanut
M&M you know what I mean he not M&M I'm
not even gonna rate these other ones
okay fair enough
other the pretzel sucks it's like
garbage
the putzel one yeah hmm but what do you
guys think of the peanut M&M I love you
know ma'am asked here yeah I think
that's true Wow that's clear whoa Wow
Ian yeah probably a tear but wow this is
universal praise almost I didn't see
praise like this I shot this is gonna
happen now a lot cuz there's a lot I
haven't okay and yeah it's just an M&M
plus a Pinot and if you like peanut then
it's it's more than that I don't care
about matters I'm saying like if I just
throw peanut my mouth I'm not caring
that much about it this is a magic
perfection it's perfection all right
boom we all agree well that's him that's
great because we didn't have a universal
praise for a candy like that since
starbursts and I'm I don't I
suggest the next one go ahead you there
little hamburger bring it up the
hamburger is like so iconic
now then apparently you didn't even know
about it never heard of it before and
disgusting and then didn't even try one
like this guys dude you're being such a
dick
it looks like plastic you can see it's
just not the way I am burger stop you
got the priority the pickles separated
from the cheese actually it's only three
pieces
no does does anyone not know about this
beauty everyone knows about them your
eyes look like hamburgers mmm it's not
that good it's not that bad dumb but
it's a little hamburger candy I know
you're giving it too many points for
cutesiness it's not bad to be honest you
know pretty good for try this I'm gonna
eat it's not not doing it you're not too
good to eat a hamburger probably gotten
in it using that as my excuse but you
ate everything else that's true barbers
definitely as gelatin in it you uh yeah
probably probably this go ahead and I'm
almost got a pinion back down it's kind
of nostalgic for me because I used to
eat him as a kid yeah I mean - so they
even made it out to Israel yeah you guys
put it upside down yeah but the
hamburger kind of works either way for
me it's a bee
I'll go it'll be all I hear is Dan rub
bleeding through a bag and nothing else
you guys anyone come on I got a bag come
on in
I haven't tried it yet Dan's rummaging
okay I couldn't find any more all right
well let's just give it whatever you
don't need our ratings on all of them
I'm curious we needed is it just off rip
that's probably a D for me just I don't
like I don't think you I did not need to
hear that
such I give it a B all right you guys
about you brought it down to it no it
stays on B it stays that be that
compromise actually vote you like well
they want my that's true you up that
maybe you guys demanded my opinion so no
I gave you didn't try it you didn't try
it you're out you guys want you guys put
it back you guys went out of your way
you guys went all over town to find
these hamburgers we bought like five of
them I don't know what's nu about five
of them she'll find the rest so what is
going on here to undermine the hamburger
rating yeah I'm gonna find one person
can I get that back it's Abby put it
back at B then I have a D I can't they I
got an F and a deal I'll find one for
Ian we should move on we can't we can't
spend this much time on each one this is
gonna be like a four hour all right it
stays at sea until he enjoys it
I'm sorry it's Democratic next up let's
do the UM New York these are great York
boring it's meant it's chocolate
I haven't had one in a while grandma
loves that snooze stop I'll take a
junior mint but let's call me inside
Ian's got a burger Wow that hard damn
well let's focus on them on the mint
it's a D for me it's a bee I like it
it's a big junior mint oh you guys look
like hamburgers knocks on new york not a
huge fan are you guys not gonna
participate oh I'd give it an E it's too
much peppermint that's the problem it's
really minty you have mmm yeah it's lame
so what I gave it a B it's a D reform
yeah really yeah yeah yeah I'll go deep
I love how I love one when
and gives an answer it's he's so
confident yeah like we did we have we
spent so much time being thoughtful and
and you know going over it but with Ian
its D yeah man of action I just know I
know in my heart did you decide on the
hamburger I'm on my last piece I'm on
the line it's the same thing are we
giving to your I was giving the Arkadiy
yes it's not as bad as almond joy we can
agree to that the almond joy army was
out for blood yeah but those people that
last week as people probably like thinks
the launch would taste like soap the one
in go ahead it's a d b it's so boring
there's no place you are boring don't
dare call the hammer your boring we're
moving on the Milky Way is perfection
caramel chocolate nougat
Snickers already done it hurt Rob
perfectly portion look I'm more caramel
no peanuts Milky Way fun fun sighs mmm
miss amazing for me it's just the
Snickers with no peanuts
what sassy hey I like it I don't like
everything Zac and him I've given an air
mm I got OC okay so where I be I always
wait for Ian's rating like that's like
the big definitive one I think he just
takes this there's there's blocks have
developed there's the Dan and ela block
but he's quiet he deliberates mm-hmm
you know it's like the swing vote it's
like nobody else matters right it's like
the mountains yes I'm the Ken bone of
candy you know neither Ken bone what's
next
baby let's do water mom okay I like
airheads but it's a bit much for me it's
like starbursts but worse cuz that first
right the curve is steeper tastes great
just turn into like sand in your mouth I
love the format I think it's awesome
yeah girl oh girl if not food it's like
why is not another thing there's a lot
of variation between the flavors on air
I can't finish their heads but so we're
gonna be eating the blue one back here
which is a little different than when
you got here split that up I'm done I
can't like I always have this problem
with airhead but halfway through I'm so
over it you don't try the orange why can
you not throw stuff at me so I like it
what would I rate it I wish that I had
confidence in decision I loved airheads
growing up II like a that was yeah that
was kind of disappointing for me when I
remembered it being it was not as good
you can't even finish it effect as a kid
you can yeah as a kid like exactly you
have to be under the age of like 12 to
be able to eat yeah this just
I think I only think it's a deed maybe
even an eat if I'm being really
prejudice no well let's hear from
wildcards I'm actually with you on this
one I say D as well okay people are not
gonna like the e for disappointing
people are not gonna like this but I
urge them to go try an airhead as an
adult
yeah don't cuz I I went into this
thinking was gonna be like a I loved
airheads growing up but this is the
first one I've had in 20 years and it
was not as good as I remember this gives
you you know features may be an anal
figure yeah then after you then I'd
given him D anybody its 3ds the drumroll
I give it a seat oh it's good at 3d it's
just 2d then the D holds yeah the D
holds firm people are gonna like that I
want dude twizzler I love you guys
unwrapped it for me okay
let me talk about twizzler it's bold and
I'll tell you why but it's not overly
sweet it's almost like you're just
chewing on wax mm-hmm but I like it it's
a refreshing that it's not so sweet it's
like wax that you can swallow I had a
weird relationship with this cuz a what
you touched by it Twix no white was
there when I was first injured when I
was first introduced to it I think by
you
it seems so weird to me because it looks
like it would be so tasty and sweet but
then it's like no flavor almost mm-hmm
so I thought I hated it but then the
more I eat it now I love it so it's a
really bold that it's so not sweet this
is enough you know what in you beat me
to it this [ __ ] sucks
I mean other than the candy it's like
awful but addicting I don't give it a
half no I'm not go I like I can't see
one candy on this list that I'd grab
before like
this would be the last one I've grabbed
out of all of these if they're all on a
table you know it might be the first for
me sometime depending on my mood Wow
yeah me too yeah exactly I love liqueurs
no but do you like twizzle I do yeah I'd
give it I'd give it a bee gees I give it
a bead we have two apps and three B's
where's that plan does I think that
lands us like good D or C right I think
it's to see ya well three B's right
three B's two F's I think it was there's
a sea Krait you guys had such a negative
reaction doesn't do generous but
whatever what didn't you like about it
that it was just waxy and not didn't
have to play very little flavor yeah it
tastes like you're eating a candle yeah
man it's like wax you can swallow it's
exciting remember in Halloween used to
get like the the Dracula fangs that were
made of wax you can put in your mouth
but you wanted to eat it but you
couldn't because it was actually just
wax but this is you can eat this yeah
would you rather eat a twizzler or a
candy corn damn well there those are
both the bottom for me those are those
are my F candies I would yeah list is
that the candy corns at D that's absurd
nerds nerds block hell no but what can
you do I would rather eat a democracy
democracy sucks
an American let's go
think I can play Rolo Tony Brown town
without getting clamped is that
necessary Adult Swim wheel gig we get
claim well Tim and Eric have a song
about Rollo's where they go Rollo Tony
Brown town check yourself right at the
door and they clump they're trying to
make a pitch for Rolo's and their
clowning out there like it's like gum
you want to spit it out you can't now
I think you guys are gonna tired of
hearing me say this but I love for all
those caramel and chocolate
it's delicious I [ __ ] love it but
little nuggies they're like little
rabbit poops it's just not coming
pellets
not my preferred candy it's behind oh so
I don't know what to rate it
that's pretty good Rollo Tony Browntown
I would never sell Fred at the door
i stir buys a lot when I was a kid I
think I might actually be the first
Rollo
I've ever had I'm kind of impressed it's
pretty good
Wow Dan I'll give it see I'll give it a
B I give it a B the only downside for me
is the rapper I like the rapper I hear
what you're saying I think it's fun that
it comes in a tube
I'd give us see this is a B for me I'm
gonna sneak it right in the be like a
Tetris piece so is this really
interesting our people at home yellow
we're soaking the show nobody thing and
they're like ooh that's interesting
people seem to really like tearless I
don't know I will do a tier list of
anything man this is gonna be the tier
list we'll do an app you know with the
tier list of at the but rock bottom
episodes the h3 pod for me the hundred
grand is almost like it's Underground
all right bring I never had my first
hundred grand until I was like 13 and
I've been brainwashed all these years
being like Oh Snickers Milky Way all
this yada yada yada Twix
but don't sudden chewy caramel milk
chocolate crispy crunchy and I'm like
dude where have you been my all that
it's so good the caramel the crunch give
me a minute
back up thank you
god I love it it's a name so boring we
got a problem back here I don't think we
have hundred grands huh
[ __ ] I know what I don't know man I'm
digging through our candy right now I
mean I only took um buy it from get
inside yeah grab this all right and you
off the back end road I did a clean bite
oh I just found him hold on because I
just wipe you this good off there and
you better not do that what do you give
it ela so boring probably a C or
something like that that's a B for me
I think they suffer from weak packaging
doesn't jump out it's true I would never
grab this off the shelf but I was so
impressed with it with the candy bar
itself I think it's fantastic
I'd give it an act and a that's my guy
Zach right there
I'm actually exciting one of you guys
this time it's really good right more
experience I don't think I've ever had a
hundred grand cuz it just seems like an
old person candy for slowly yeah but
it's actually pretty good I give it a
beat so we maybe see what was yours
I went dad again I'm be on this one okay
I think we're a B my gran it's kind of a
dark horse there and did not expect to
like that so wait there was two A's and
three B's no you look everybody's no
means that gave it at both is or did you
give it a beam hey yeah I guess it was
too much to H to be isn't it to be I
thought you gave it a B Ethan to be I
kind of want to sneak it up in the a but
Snickers you can I don't know what this
one is
you guys no fun dip oh boy this [ __ ] is
so shocking like it took me ten years to
even realize what I was supposed to do
with
until I saw some other kids with it and
and then even as a child I was somewhat
horrified by how disgusting it it was
what you're supposed to do helo is open
the top like this yeah
and now what you'll find here is a stick
oh I've never seen this the stick I
loved I would just eat the stick and
throw the rest out well dip it in the
powder yeah not that complicated like
chalk or sugar you think then that's
this guy's thing
no because kids would be just drooling
all over it and dipping in it gets all
wet and spit yeah I think it's
disgusting
I hate [ __ ] your mouth too it was
awesome I did that I give that and he
Wow the stick tastes like [ __ ] feels
kind of blown away right now experiment
she's in the laboratory yeah I find it
disgust I am feel disgusting eating it
but it's good I don't discuss it's gross
what is this you're it's just you just
dip just straight up sugar what is
everything else I mean your mouth is all
blue yeah okay write it then tough guy
I'm thinking all right Ian are you like
crunching the numbers are you doing like
out of them in your head right now I'm
eating it I could have a beat I'm okay
wait Abby this is Annie wait you said D
or B EE no no
oh I said B okay yeah I'm gonna dig it
thank you this is the first time we've
ever agreed him I don't like working
when I eat my candy this is a job work
this is pleasure Jill so Zack is the
wild card for once we've got two bees
and two E's you are the swing vote
Cirie's act I'd give it a D I think that
probably bland sit in a C then a or D I
think that lands on Indy yeah these
sucks it belongs there such a task it's
there's a lot okay
these MMS are [ __ ] let's just get
these out of the way yeah cuz it's way
too much [ __ ] still here [ __ ] delete
delete
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] now here we go
a rule it's like mmm
MMS from the future the only moon it's
like Robocop mmm style I love it look
it's a little waxy if you eat too many
personally I'm not a fan
Wow me it's a name love it
wait did you rate it higher than the
cups I like him more than the cop oh I
am i rocking more than the cops I do I
do it - well whoever invented that is a
genius or like we've got the cops now we
need the pieces I like the pieces - I
want to rate it a B but I feel like
that's that's [ __ ] up - put it on the
same level as the cuffs but apparently
what did I say I think I give it a see
here okay well it's a bee I'll give it a
beep it's just not my personal taste but
I get it
so I could see it being a bee hmm
I'm just not into the peanut butter
stuff I don't have a fetish for peanut
butter I just know good candy when I
taste it I agree
so I'll just sit here quietly waiting
for you guys I'll give it a beat see hey
I guess it's a beating I'm not a peanut
butter gonna either the bee is getting
crowded
B is getting crowded folks this okay
yeah you guys about that extreme sour do
they all say extreme sour or is this a
special edition extreme sour I mean I
went to three stores and this is all
they had at all three well there you go
okay so then less where's a sour man is
like sour
these are [ __ ] bomb last year I love
it s ass I love this our gang where are
you guys crawling no no yes yes all the
way it's not as for medium I liked the
texture a lot the texture is amazing
it's like that hard chewy yep but it's
just it's too sour
uh-huh let's just see for me yeah this
is C oh look at me I'm suffering no time
it's a good supper no all right that's 3
s's to seize i say that's a name yeah at
least not at leas you can't get a s for
this controversy
no that's the warheads bro wait did you
take a warhead no no come in though wait
are we really giving sweet tarts an A
yes
wait two seas and two S's oh three areas
oh [ __ ] 3 s's and twosies yeah i guess
that's a name as much as i dislike it i
don't think it belongs there that's an
M&M level
Snickers level you died milk died look
at this beauty okay for callers love the
texture the texture I'll get eyes is
perfect the texture is vent I love the
texture I love hard chewy is what she
said when she
all right let's blast these three
musketeers nobody let's just take a
quick bite
wow it's missing everything instruction
little nugget nougat where's all the
good joke like these candy bars it's
like Mexican food you know how they're
all very the same thing
Thanks Snickers not at all Milky Way
doesn't have peanuts and Three
Musketeers has nothing that being said I
think it's pretty good and I can I'm
kidding I gave it a be one of my
favorites I'd give it an A it's like
eating fiberglass this is me fiberglass
[Music]
like the are you talking about like
insulation like the pink foam it is kind
of like up what Thank You Danielle's not
so bad okay as far as like a chocolate
bar goes there pretty shitty as well
[ __ ] you Dan
so it sounds like it's like a a D or SC
okay well I think it's I don't care I
don't care either no we know we need to
protect the integrity we had I gave it a
B I was with you under B those two bees
and a and - it's a series it's a C let's
not rush through this but in a lot of
work well time to tear L can really see
after your mama yeah you know I complain
about hard candy but to me the tootsie
roll can be the perfect day and the
perfect time you know mm-hmm it's
actually I regret not remembering these
last week when we were talking about the
tootsie roll cuz I still contend them
actual tootsie roll is absolute garbage
and the tootsie roll pop is basically
they had so much unsold [ __ ] [ __ ]
roll because nobody touch it they put
some good candy around it yeah
the in the middle of this lollipop is a
tootsie roll yeah you always throw it
away once you get down to that because
it's more oh I love it it's coated in
hard candy a new connection to it is
like a best thing ever which it's a
great lollipop but a great we'll get to
that core that's like as soon as you
break my I would never buy this but your
mom always has it in a in their house
and I always grab one mm-hmm so what
would you write that I don't know could
be to me the lollipop part is like an A
and then the tootsie roll is garbage so
that kind of brings it down to like a C
when you average it out yeah it's a beer
I'd give it an A
Thank You Zach I give it an A - finally
so what I give it a B - a like a bee bee
me average that surprised me at that one
Ian in a sin didn't you mad talk on the
tootsie roll Ian well it's the it's the
lollipop factor right it's great I love
the wrapper it's colorful and so when I
got one of these in the Halloween bag it
was always a big score I forgot they
were even talking about Halloween all
right let's go to the warhead just doing
that everyone's waiting for this is Big
E let's never had a warhead I don't know
if I never had one but you can get
[ __ ] wrecked I'm gonna get rekt you
want black cherry or blue raspberry try
that women I think the blue will be more
sour lemon it's already sour dude just
look at it it looks like it's coated in
like cyanide it looks like it was found
at the bottom of a well haha I can't do
this when I was a kid I used I would
have to spit it out
dan was telling us before the show they
can burned the taste buds off his song
you ready you got it you can't you got
it just throw it in your mouth and see
how long you can take it all right I'll
do it with you oh my god take it out
you're with me right
I just tasted it for a second and I was
shocked just throw it in your mouth you
like the sour candies mister sweetheart
it gets sweet it gets weird yeah it gets
sweep so as long as you can take it
ready go I'm not salivating I'm just
holding his stuff I got a clamp down on
it I'm trying on to taste it but it's so
awful
okay and I made it through you make it
through and then a few becomes the hard
candy and now Candy's good and then
there's a surprise on the inside too
when you crack it open clamp down on DA
approved like I see you guys my tongue
feels like damage someone was
administering a lethal dose of something
to me this would like like why am i
hearing this because you're gonna eat
this too right now really I made it
through Wow I made it through you know
they used to do as a kid I just remember
IANS walking in disbelief you know what
I used to do with these you guys didn't
call me a little [ __ ] but I'll tell you
own it
ISO wash it in the sink huh wash all the
sour off and then heat it cuz the sweet
parts really good
on American I don't like it I don't
think kids should eat that is what I
think what American there's something
not right about kids but not in their
mouth it was like my mouth is burned
there needs to be like a Shawn heaven
show sour one American but you gotta get
to the center apparently they're just an
interesting in the center damn there's
yeah there's like a little pop of like
super sweet I don't know something I
wanted open I know I didn't want to kill
it but you made me good wives in half
[ __ ] no that's no way asked here all the
way way warheads boy you know I'm gonna
be more fair I think it's in I don't
know how to rake this because I know
it's the shock fact it's not that bad
but for me I would I would never got my
bag I wouldn't I wouldn't even need it I
mean I would throw it out but there is
something to the shock there's an
originality point for sure so we have
two S's yes sir
you see see for me in that's the whole
range you guys what's an effort I think
I think I'm as to a fantasy it's not an
F like I think I give it it yeah I'm
with your opinion I think that that that
probably rates it up be on average which
i think is fair
cuz it's a it is a hotly contested item
it's not for everybody but for if you're
if you're into it some bomb-ass can is
it an it is an S candy
it is totally in s candy Wow well not in
this term and i'm democratic process
that you wanna have a revolt yeah like
it's not quite universal it's exactly s
candy is universal appraised Zach I love
it peanut butter mmm that's s here yeah
alright let's move it all quickly I love
to this dish it's like twister gum right
I don't know a Swedish about him isn't
but it tastes great mmm-hmm I really
like them I think they're
be be there okay see for me I guess it's
generous maybe even deep let's go deep a
steer for now now come on you out of
control that I know I love them you can
have that me ask your candies
why not compromises the integrity of
your ass I'll give it a deep
did you just unamerican yourself South
American that's pretty arrogant in your
self would you give it D
give it a D your D you guys are pushing
me down it's a B again I think or D
you're not ready yet I was at a B with
you about to be okay I mean B is the
root is the kind of the curve you know
what I mean it's starting to look that
way
we're all enjoy down there bye okay so
here's one I think that it's the only
one there cuz because so here no one
wants that could possibly content so the
Smarties oh here we go
no way so the Smarties was something
that was in your Halloween bag and
access every year no one with all of
Smarties and I aid I mean I it's so bad
it's like it looks like a cran I mean
it's so bad how can you hate a they're
just wrong with you guys it's just tums
I give it out it with the other candy so
and to help your stomach you say that
like that's a bad thing damn yeah
exactly I love Tom's it's just shocky
boring I mean this is like you guys are
insane if you lived in a sewer Society
and this was like the best they could do
with candy because they don't have
access to like higher technologies like
this is like a this is like I'm eating
the whole thing while you were talking
okay go ahead I'm just saying like if
you were in like prehistoric
civilization and they just found out
about sugar I didn't have really
sophisticated ways of making stuff this
is like
it's a F ah that's enough mojo that with
you
Smarties suck and they pissed me off
Tibby for me and I have bad memories of
having bags full of Smarties everybody
cuz you try and trade with the other
kids nobody wants you smarty nobody
wants the smart everyone's got a
thousand of them guys are party poopers
on American yep
what else let's go hit us I'd give it an
act my god there's no there's no there's
no consensus in this would be I'm moving
to the sewer
hold on we got an a a B a B and two F's
so what does that make that a C no I do
a D yeah no it can't be they liked it
said an a to bees and chefs I guess it
is it D yeah that's like a D because you
got two F that's yeah that brings up way
down I mean it really belongs there on
that [ __ ] tier next to corn and fun dip
I can't believe that I mean it's got a D
at least if it was any higher than D I
think okay well here's the other one
that I thought would be a contender
dum-dums there's another [ __ ] that you
get in your bag you like give me a break
just some stupid little sucker it sucks
there's nothing interesting about it the
doctor do it it's time to eat all dum
dum yeah they're called dum-dums it's
tiny there's nothing interesting in the
center there's no ingenuity that's a
half-and-half just right off the bat
yeah you can't get a flavor profile with
the quick look like that I don't like
like you said it looks like the dentist
gave it to me
it's so small that was the one who and i
who i just you know i just put into oop
i just put in watermelon one in my mouth
I don't like it what's a D you know it's
Annie oh Jenny yeah if you guys want me
to be fair it's an it's an ass I was
going to eat that
it's an Arab I
wouldn't even bother to pick it up it's
an F honestly and honestly ofc maybe
even a B this watermelon one is fire
shut up try the one what are these
called
Smarties yeah absolutely not
[ __ ] you Dan I'm gonna stick to Rolaids
thanks hmm I'm sorry I told you to shut
up
that was rude of me okay I guess oh I
forgot overwhelmed in the heat of the
moment no I mean this is a debate man
that's okay shouldn't you gotta peel
like that yeah you got to be passionate
all right Ian it's a cube it [ __ ]
Bret what do i what am i doing it
reminds me of the doctor I'm giving it
an F thank you yes I'll give it a beat
thank you what okay let me turn it
around on you before we rush to
conclusions here we have three FS am i
right yeah and I give it a C and he'd
give it a B so that's a e for sure so I
think we have almond joy joy that seems
unfair well got three ABS right I mean
as far as our rating system problems you
call dumb dumb if I had a home enjoying
a dumb-dumb in a boy total [ __ ]
bowling you know I mean I want one of
those it's such a depressing candy yeah
it's the worst candy it is it really is
f tear and now glare who made this no
charisma call it a dumb down rapidly and
doctors office I just can't believe we
don't have anything in the FT r there's
got to be one thing in there good barb
it's her she's with peanuts in that [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
you can't trick me I know it's Hershey's
and I still hate it E
it's even worse because they treat me
like a fool mrs. you're a good barb
awful name - might I add e it said D for
me because it's done
as bad as his nose I just don't like
that they're trying to fool me into
thinking it's which is a Hershey bar
yeah I almost want to dock it points for
that tag trying to pull a fast one every
day even in half I want to see something
on the FTA no no no no come on keep it
real here but we just got to keep it
real
no I really I would never buy that trip
it is kind of the worst yeah I said see
they could do his gun so we got a FFP
damn would you give it I was given I
would say learn to be a D but again I'm
docking at points for like trying to I
think it's a [ __ ] Hershey's bar is it
it's a D I guess yeah it's the same as
Hershey's but it should be less than
hers that's why I feel right just for
being an [ __ ]
okay let's be honest here we got to be
promise lis again we come back to her
seat but at least this time it looks
different this one is very innovative
you know what I mean like it takes a
little technological advance why do you
do it it takes a little technological
throws it on the table like I'm gonna
scoop the table Wow
okay this is definitely the best now
what I what I love about it is like how
packed it is when with cookies oh yeah
it's like it's an amazing cold gray and
that's a very American that's American
how its they give you the value yeah I
think it Sam I'm impressed I give it a
name I was gonna say a wow this is an
area baby yeah well we have a full
consensus here five is you know her she
really they really did a they turned it
around yeah I'm impressed
they went from dog [ __ ] mr. Goodbar guys
mr. Goodbar has to be in half I'm
looking at this I'm looking at this
[ __ ] mr. Goodbar I can't stand the
name
yeah everything about it it's more
attention she's like I'll tell you how
far I'm giving it an F you kid that's
not Democrat let's review the package
for a second
could it be any ugly how does anyone
buying that so looks like a cleaning
product surprise her she's embarrassed
even put their name on oh man
alright the last ones payday it's gonna
be another nobody cares right all right
you're undercutting all right paydays
packed with nuts held together by
caramel looks like yeah everything I
don't you like go give it a shot
this looks disgusting yeah there's like
a little note like it know when you poop
is that like yeah it looks like the in
your intestine make a bigger right not
really take it the whole experience okay
maybe I get some of the fillings yeah
okay I got it's fine it's a C I fell
asleep you did all right guys go on
American that [ __ ] there's nothing good
about nothing yeah I give it a C for me
thing is now right I love the middle of
the peanut buttery unis you know you
like paydays watches snicker it's got
that salty and sweet it's like really
salty
it is very salty I like that like I'll
really like salted caramel dessert kind
of stuff this reminds me of it so so we
got an a we got to seize and we got a F
I had a E so it sounds like a sea
yeah it's down there maybe even well
yeah sure you got
you have a different opinion well hold
on ela what what do you want have to say
about this damn no I'm going I mean the
consensus is what it is
I just you guys are all wrong that's
what I don't even think this but just to
play devil's advocate for a second I
just keep going back to this dumb dog
you really said that
what do you mean yam it's so good he's I
just keep going back to this one I love
it well how was it in even him does that
mean you didn't liked it I didn't give
it any and gave me like an area yeah but
it's in E all right let's talk about the
candy at hands sour patch kids hazen
classic s and s has love you don't even
have to try it's enough p.m. I got a try
one hold on other what well let them try
it is serious
wait did all four of you give it s yeah
dad before trying it you know that's not
true
Ian be honest they're not mmm what's so
good if after all this candy I'm still
eating up mm-hmm
there's perfect balance mm-hmm sour
sweet chewy
that's all happening back up from Mike
it's the gummy [ __ ] is the worst I like
mr. head up in this [ __ ] ah that's a
beef for me I think it still holds that
yes four 4s is one B does not I think
that's a whole good ass yep up there
boom don't Erica have any of our s has
been non-unanimous besides that one I
think so yeah I think 2x and KitKat
right starboard starburst wasn't wasn't
unanimous I give it a a yeah so there
you go
or a B then I gave it there it is that's
the tier list now if I the only one we
all agreed on was them in him peanuts
Hershey's no four 4s
I think we all said everyone's wigs
right I know anybody not feel like
twixes and s cuz it's because it's an
ass alright don't remember well just
right now I think peanut butter and this
I think the peanut butter M&M have a
concise I don't know if I see twixes and
ass it's fine with me
this is awesome yeah on American the
ones that I have the biggest beef with
looking at this list because there is no
EFT here and I'm being honest mr.
Goodbar is a [ __ ] FD r-- I like it
revised I think that Bart is such dog
[ __ ] so pathetic there's nothing of
value in that
let's drop it down there I mean doesn't
you know that's my vote I'm I'm in favor
should we revote on mr. Goodbar yeah I'm
in favor of dropping a tough Ian flush
it I don't think it's an ass I wouldn't
accept a knee okay well then what how
did you even get up when it Inadi like
what happened in our rating system Ian
gave it like a s or something insane
[ __ ] I'd rather eat it than a regular
Hershey's that's indeed
dude what okay what about what did you
see the package so what about dum-dums
and you guys are loving the dum-dums if
I can't get that I'm just trying to
figure out if there's a true F here all
candy corn it's the candy corn I'm enjoy
[ __ ] everything up I'm know I'm not
the only one that likes candy corn Zach
and Ian both like candy corn yeah it's
the almond Joey that's enough it's not
we're like way it's the Goodbar it's the
[ __ ] good Bart you all know it we're
well out of the average by having the
candy corn that I agree I mean we like
the candy corn you got to give it up all
right
three people liked it in this room of
five people I know but the it's Banali
it's normal it's not an anomaly do it do
it Twitter poll then let's see when we
post this episode done oh well they
won't know what we're talking about
well no okay go ahead do it all the way
uncle [ __ ] just like do like what we
have to
we're already got no idea
[ __ ] you Dan for me though the only one
I mean dum-dums mr. Goodbar is F for me
those are just truly pointless yeah but
again we couldn't agree on that really
mr. Goodbar Ian I can't get over that
look at it yellow and red I'm not gonna
budge on this all right there you have
it um sure nice was gonna come murder us
by the way I don't know if I just want
to remind you that oh yeah that's fine
oh you want to order food Ian I just
want to sleep don't the pole Leigh we
got to wrap it up boy have to talk about
bail Delphine I don't want to talk about
it Zack was the one that was banging my
no what do you mean what do you mean
what do I mean Zack is always the ending
the earth like after our oh sure he sent
me the new video I'm sure with like
saliva emoji was like okay don't you
have a girlfriend
I do let's watch it
I've got all the good parts time-stamped
are you doing a poll down yep so let me
just see because I don't want to get
started and then get interrupted with
the poll so let's just find out let's
get the real feedback we should be ready
to DT right that's what we gave it yeah
I was D all right I'm tweeting it now
yeah it's dt r how are you phrasing the
poll yeah good question
how did you feel about us rating candy
corn dt r no no no no no that's are
loaded it's already the way you say you
say you say s ABCDEF no great candy corn
we're not giving them
why'd you let them write it dude but
you're giving them
that's not a good biased poll that's a
total loaded potential it's actually way
more biased all right well then what am
I waiting for you gotta do the scientist
delete that tweet okay how did you
actually word it how do you feel about
its rating candy corn dt r it's either
okay or it's an F or it made me lose all
respect and I got to tell you the it's
an F is winning by a lot already so yeah
but you wait the best option is it's
okay it's okay
that's a horribly loaded yeah you have
you cannot you can't reveal what you
want the answer would be in the poll Dan
that's why I'm saying it has to be tier
ass through F so that the people can
decide on their own but you you're
you're influencing the poll you're at
you're playing God mmm go lower
did we raise candy corn as a result of
this poll high corn here's a taste of
the responses candy corn tastes like my
depression dang I meant to put it
belongs in the Shadow Realm
it's too [ __ ] high do we raise it no
you don't touch it all of its
compromised in the poll we can
compromise this chart I think all right
in let's make a trade I move candy corn
up to C and we move mr. Goodbar down to
1/2 I'm in favor of I like I like candy
corn I'd rather you can turn them
whoppers or nerds really [ __ ] smart
use I just can't believe that what about
over an Almond Joy I would rather eat it
overall enjoy
I mean anything over an Almond Joy so
why do you want no almond joys not a nap
I think it's in he candy there's the
thing about almond joy we can if we can
labor this conversation even further
is that there is something novel about
it there's no creative would you ever
reach for four no but there's something
creative there's some spark of life in
it somebody cared about the creation of
this band you got mr. Goodbar they don't
even think it's just battered some
peanuts and our Hershey's and tried to
rebrand it it said just longer hurry
it's really not it's a real anything Dum
Dums is even worse it's like a tiny
little big dollop of coffe hard candy at
least they called himself now Yeah right
they own it mr. Goodbar is a bonafide F
there's nothing good about an Almond Joy
over this I agree there's nothing good
about it but there's a spark of life ow
coconut in the almond it's terrible fine
but you're not listening to music it's
about the the intention it's about the
artistries about the creativity of it
the presentation is terrible the worst
thing I've ever seen it literally looks
like a DGL van at least there's
something comforting about it
almond joys just like unknown
territories join the name I need a good
bar over a gummy burger whoa no the
gummy burger is the one that likes the
good bar to begin with so what what is
your the hamburgers beloved it's not
moving all I'm saying
an almond joy should be you know well I
disagree mr. Goodbar should be a [ __ ]
F so why don't we compromise let's put
them both down
that's not compromise that's yeah the
only thing you're compromises the
integrity of the tier list we're ending
this conversation yeah in I'm pissed at
you I can't what else is new I can't
believe like like really that's that's
you want to fall on your sword on the
Goodbar sword so how is Nepal doing okay
people that were okay
with our rating is 35% and then the
other two compound are what 65 so
basically they're loaded and ass
pathetic Rick's point two percent of the
people lost all respect for the podcast
let's move on you're trying to rig the
game you're like you're you trying to
meddle in our lectures fake news fake
news and by the way even by your fake
news poll Dan thirty percent still like
it we go home we gotta end this
conversation
dick order some Veggie girl so order
some fried food to wash down all this
crap okay good and could put put a note
on my burger extra fried all right Roger
extra almond joy
yeah can you melt some almond joy in my
burger it's exhausting there's too much
what candy debate it's taking a lot out
of me man well the good news is Bell
Delphine's back that should energize us
she's back your favorite killing your
favorite kitty girl who's into daddy Dom
let's see what she and Olivia was making
us talk about this again yeah Eva does
have respect for Bell and so do i she's
a character she's funny too and the
actual content a little weird for me
okay so what I think is going on is it
says how to become Bell Delphine she's
playing with the skeleton trying to cast
an incantation on the skeleton to turn
it into Belle Delphine and I think it's
meant to be a Halloween spooked Oberer
video came out November 4th however so I
think that people were confused by that
regardless let's take a look this is my
friend mr. skeleton and today we're
going to turn them into Belle Delphine
[Music]
but first I have to show you that I am a
real doctor now you need an operation
table and one of these spooky boards
next you must find a large heart here is
mine
then you take a big knife and gently cut
the heart open this will show it so I
was wondering what it was it's just a
turkey I mean it's just a chicken a
whole chicken just cutting into the
breast I say yeah I was like what is
that you know this is a Jacob no Raj
because only open hearts can accept love
if you want to be a good girl
you must always keep a little space for
God in your heart make sure she's nice
and warm you put a little mother Mary
stuck together it's very special
it will stop on do you think this is a
desecration of life I mean it's a little
dramatic but well I don't know you're
you're the vegetarian yeah it's
disgusting why is she doing this it's
funny it's epic lol so random well what
she's doing for the audio listeners is
she's cut open and they breast of a raw
whole chicken and put a virgin mother
Mary in it and is covering it up with
glitter glue it's so edgy and cool Wow
dance hey didn't big-time on bow forget
Jesus must always have the deepest
position in the heart that's right woah
Ian where did that come from
she's been praising God ever since that
Connie oh that's what it is a carnie
related by the way how do you feeling
about the album after I mean I assume
you've been had the chance to take it in
I've been jam and big time praising God
it went again for the third time all
things are possible with God
[Music]
do you feel that you've made a religious
resurgence or or do you just enjoy the
music I just enjoy the music but I like
seeing people invested in that way my
teeth are so green from this
you'd like to see people praise God
praise Jesus see people believe in
something and have such a you know
passionate about it and it's just
positive there I don't know are there
are you the only I mean I just imagine
like a black church and you're the only
white guy there no as a Kanye concert
90% way and then like families combined
interesting I wish it was like that
that'd be awesome
okay well let's cut that out for the
highlight take a timestamp say make sure
your heart can't be weighed down
this will allow you to flutter through
life at your own speed
now sleep Attila I have I have to admit
then I had the same kind of reaction
where it was just like what the [ __ ] is
this
nobody's like oh so edgy like just a
little too trihard edgy yeah but there's
really impressed by by you know but
there it gets better it gets better it
does get better don't get all all right
don't get all bent out of shape
oh I thought you said banana I'm getting
a little defensive all right then don't
skip through yeah of course I'm at the
good part now remember you can't thread
the needle with your own spit if there's
a chance that this whole spell will
backed by a beautiful fall out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and here is a plaster this is especially
important for girls without father I
thought that was funny she must not have
liked a dad right daddy dome yeah what's
with the daddy Dom special girl without
a dad I mean I feel like she was just
born I feel like she was just like born
into like a sewer and somebody fished
her out like how does this girl exist I
don't know but actually has a really
lovely bedroom behind her
yeah dude from a sewer yeah now that
she's made a lot mate she does well for
herself but also her in her bedroom she
was like a buffalo or a skeleton so
that's not that kawaii is it illa here's
a another timestamp this part she
inserts the heart into the skeleton to
give it life now you have to open up
your chest and press it in now make sure
it's secure I can't just have it falling
out when you're walking around say know
what you smile the braces at some point
I don't see braces maybe it's just the
clear on the TV it could be it is a line
make sure you have a super teeth look
nice anyway this part is just like some
pickles nonsense this part
we've got rooked Anna's skull is small
and broken but it's a good place to hold
your slime so she would Dimmick welcome
Rock turner was the guy who what was the
story with Brock Eli you use the rapists
but he's got like the best mugshot like
oh he would know he was the guy that
pleaded like he was like got out for
being wealthy what'd they say he got it
like an extremely light sentence I
believe and it was very they coined a
term they coined a term for him called
like piece of [ __ ] no no about his well
thing about is what they coined some
turn about
they gave him a lighter sentence because
of his economic status I see I don't
know what term that is but let me see
but yeah there was controversy over his
lenient sentence that he got they called
it uh gosh darn it can you guys try to
figure it find that but anyway he's got
the best mug shot so she kind of she's
took a stance against rape and this
which is pretty good I mean that's think
I think that's pretty good of her what
did she say about it you got the best
mug shot doesn't that's you nice flat
fifty
it's his skull here to play time you
must be careful if you breathe in the
slime you can develop severe case of
osteoporosis Brooke Turner's skull is
small and broken but it's a good place
to hold your slash she's taken a chance
against rape what time to make it
further I feel like even even even
acknowledging that she has some moral
boundary of any kind is kind of a a
positive step for me I suppose are you
talking about the term outercourse
out of horse Rock Turner's lawyers
trying to get his attempted rape charge
overturned by coining the term
outercourse
no they didn't calling that turn first
of all no it was called first of all
then out of course is something I've
performed on illa many times of course
which is later described as fully
clothed sexual contact not to be
confused with intercourse how can you
give for his outer course for the
intercourse well what was it called I
don't know who cares
imagine this highlight cut this part I
don't know if it's raw chicken or what
doesn't look right you took something
you jerk off what does a teenager and
then just have cement shame afterwards
[Music]
interesting at any point yeah here's
this part actually it does you you'll be
happy to know that we're getting to it I
don't want to see more remember this is
why we add the razor blades this makes
sure her memory juice comes out some
memories can be hard to swallow
can't they mr. skeleton pretty epic
any thoughts yet this one shocked the
hell out what's the tear what do you
rate this video on the terror list
alright well get ready hold on to your
buckets because this one shook me
alright
[Applause]
[Music]
today I'm only halfway through kameez on
the growth Wow okay what was this post
just a couple days I mean just like two
days ago or yesterday yes we know
yesterday it was supposed to yesterday
was it just a Halloween meme that yes it
was a holiday it's a Halloween meme
that's late oh that's my assumption at
all right well does that help
I did say that it's bad when I yeah so
but it gets good at the end I think
you'll enjoy it for months for her to
come back well no I think they're happy
that they at least have come from I
don't wish she wasn't drafted into a sex
trade yes
I've got to wrap it up in like 15
minutes is this how you want to spend
the last minutes of this episode well
I'm almost done yes you enjoy I like the
video Ethan thank you
how would you rate it on a tier list
he's just it's up there with the good
bar I think okay but it's almost not
just come on throw me a bone here look
at this beautiful thing it looks just
like her
your internet families good luck and
most importantly have fun mr. skeleton
no so wait wait wait here you get two
okay imma skip this part
and then at the end I thought this was
interesting she licks the raw chicken
and actually gets voted out which isn't
something I thought was possible but you
know that that I thought it was
interesting that she was even disgusted
by it because I'd like to see that he's
actually human yes that she exactly if I
was her I would have kept that out
because to me she's just down for
anything
ela did not like that video I don't
think I want to watch someone play with
raw chicken
that's just Zack what do you think I
mean you're the one with the premium
snapchat oh my god I just I didn't I
didn't get it I didn't get it I mean
well to be fair we did watch it and well
to also be fair on the being fair that
is what it is yeah well we didn't watch
the part the part that pissed me off was
like who's gonna clean all that it up
okay that's where my mind goes like the
cleanup yeah that would be not fun well
probably her daddy Dom yeah actually
when I just pulled up the comments this
one top comments on the video is what
the fact someone has to clean up this
mess makes me sad they probably did on a
tarp you know if they're smart and they
just wrapped it up all day I mean
someone's filming yeah and her and I
have to say the sitter stole the Virgin
or insulin on saint virgins but in cells
she was with a guy at the pornhub Awards
is that right in well I don't see right
now what I don't remember seeing anybody
that wasn't it wasn't yeah
I remember there was a guy with her you
told me she was with the guy no I didn't
remember that either
I don't remember are you becoming a
beldo fan fan what is going on yeah
you're actually watching this well I had
to watch it for the show remember that
I'm just saying it for Zach because
alright I'll side with the other side
with you
thank know it's back am I in the hot see
right now I mean come on
I like this fine I can handle the hot
seat here I like her as an entertainer
that I know but I want to [ __ ] do you
actually like the content cuz I don't
some of it I like like the stop the
squid one was gross but I thought it was
funny and I mean there was a good moment
like when she pulled up they that ar-15
I was like what the [ __ ] but like but
we're going to read in the past like you
know the the length that she'll go to
make a joke like with the fake arrests
and all this I mean you know that stuff
was funny but I agree you made like 10
10 times them well I'm trying to put
together a show I don't like it Cheryl
look up cutie is sustaining well yeah I
mean yes I'm kind of entertained by
watching HeLa rose to you right now what
have I done man I'm come here I lay
myself before you all you want to plan
the next show and I'll just sit in the
backseat backseat driver it I just feel
like you were a little too into this
awful video and I wasn't into it do it
how I just click through you made it
sound like there's a point to watching
it there was no point so we put it the
title the thugs people always click for
her it's not that secret it's not a big
secret we all we always get like 10
times more abusement you
that could've done when let's view a
second first time that I've been it was
appointed by the bell contest so usually
okay so why is that my fault I guess
it's not week if we should be able to
decide to collectively I'm concerned
when it seems like we're not on the same
page you know we're on the same page not
nuts what do you want me to say I mean I
thought it was funny that you were so
grossed out I thought it was funny nine
timestamps here nine one two three four
five six seven eight and the first one
is the actual is the video do you think
that I would this video was so long do
you know when I was doing research and
planning for this episode I watched it
through once first of all just to see
what it was and then the second time
just so you know I watched it at two
times speed because I don't want to sit
through the whole [ __ ] 12 minute
video so I could timestamp the
semi-interesting spot why are you making
me throw her under the bus I mean some
are hit some are miss but but she's part
of the lore of this show and together we
have to I gotta keep it real yeah and I
just question your judgment a little bit
on this video that I come out saying
this is the best video you guys gonna
love this the layer well you kind of
said like keep watching and stuff like
that well the school shooting mean
people liked that was okay there you
have it that did give me a chuckle dan
laughed quite a bit and went dead to
school shooting man yeah I guess I've
never seen a video like that there you
have it okay but okay Ian do you have
something nice to say I mean I don't
know we should check in bells are most
thumbnail person of all time like a good
amount like I would have never guessed
that that she would have been our most
thumbnail but you just follow the clicks
baby at the end of day you have you know
[ __ ] putting a picture of she you
know Vin Diesel on his balcony let me
say this picture so dalire do you
ultimately listen ultimately you think
can't talk lately like what was it you
couldn't tell me the name of some
celebrity and you said it's so wrong
ultimately if this is what gets us
clicks we'll really know who watches man
he was he's jacked and then really limp
self go man it's [ __ ] epic I love
this phone wait he was never that Jack
that's not real I don't know he was
pretty Jack look at that he's gonna set
his first name or last name is Kennedy
and he was like so or not well I called
George Bush George Washington yeah I was
pretty good what do we decide we like
bail everything else on the dock are you
gonna talk about Friday kscypher slogan
Paul there's tons of unsold tickets no
because a [ __ ] I like that put it up
either Clinic a surprising amount of
tickets unsold here look at the look at
this stadium these [ __ ] I feel like
the first time people cared it now I
mean nobody gives a [ __ ] right like
these are all available I think no but
they weren't even selling these seats I
don't know what's with this one we
looked it up cuz it's this Saturday
Indian and I were like maybe we should
go like I know would that be funny and
what I'm interested
well the the unsold I think I know why
the tickets aren't selling the Rings
tickets of which there's a ton left or
what do we see like five five fifty
apiece and that's before like fees and
everything so you know you talking like
a 600 650 ticket too I think so yeah I'm
not trying to I'm not sure but it's
gonna be hilarious cuz it's all unsold
including the second you can see where
the media section is so that's where the
cameras will be right here right and so
that one to the left of the Ring that's
like way open so it's just it's just
gonna look empty on so all of these
nosebleed sections are sold
I guess so cause there's nobody wants to
500 bucks yeah I think what would happen
if that was the cases that they would
probably just tell everyone to move in
yeah yeah they probably will I think you
know how pissed everyone be like the 180
people that yeah I mean there was a
decent amount of those expensive ones
sold but well according to the about
half half the seats were available still
there are still well over six thousand
tickets available including a healthy
portion of the cheapest tickets which
were priced at forty one dollars some
sections in fact are completely
available yeah including some of the
floor sections behind the media only a
handful of tickets have been sold for
the going rate of five hundred and
seventeen dollars I mean what Logan Paul
fan has five hundred dollars to drop on
this [ __ ] did the first time was novel I
don't think anyone cares this time I
mean I really don't yeah that's that's
done you know I was like a guy who why
to you know what I heard that affair I
just looked it up capacity of staples is
21,000 so there's 6,000 tickets left I
mean they did so like probably 10 to
15,000 tickets that's a lot but but oh
they're made most of money on
pay-per-view last year too because
ultimately it cost so much puts a
production like that on yeah that there
I heard that yeah I mean the vast
majority of the money they made was from
pay-per-view they had like a million
pay-per-view sales is the food here down
but we gotta wait for the food so might
as well go until it's here
we have to go over some tiny fry stuff
so do you want to talk about the boomers
the n-word or what saved that hey maybe
save it so I'm going a long time so let
me just finish this I'm really in candy
the candy always loves us up we got all
along all right
service well this is looking good there
their service is unavailable currently
to buy tickets really huh just try again
huh crash on the website Staples Center
what's with these URLs at eff percentage
F percentage 2f percentage 2f like a
thousand times
explain that to me and Dani I well I
guess we'll save these stories but
tik-tok is being investigated for being
a Chinese data farm which is awesome in
hilarious would you people are being
paid three thousand dollars to be
intentionally inflected with influenza
infected with the flu influenza the rare
h1z1 h1n1 oh that one yeah like they're
really not only [ __ ] oh wow
3k though at ball so you have to be
under surveillance for a week so it's
pretty gnarly [ __ ] swine flu swine
flu did how much 3 grand
yeah but also you have to sit in a in a
laboratory for a week of your life
come on we are worse fates I guess yeah
there are worse fates like dying of the
flu which could happen okay your 3 grand
though there you go hey just a quick
update we've got 3,300 votes on this
poll so far the poll is invalid talking
it's relevant
43% it's an F 21% made me lose all
respect all sinks it's dead on arrival
to be fair then and I was on your side
the poll is not fair the poll is like
why even rating me that crap it's like
building a boat with holes in it yes
on arrival all right so anyway Logan
Paul versa case I any predictions on
that I mean I'm gonna watch the
highlights but I could predict everyone
loses because it's stupid anybody
involved loses Wow nice edgy joke though
honestly didn't spend 12 minutes making
it that's how long that video was 12
minutes I think they put more effort in
than 12 minutes what'd I miss
I mean he said he put 12 man you said I
was being edgy and I said at least my
edginess Wednesday three seconds I'm
like that [ __ ] bell why are you I'm
the host why Jeff and Tom you wrap it up
and I and I am are you [ __ ] with me
where's the pizza max just going nuts
with the soundboard he spamming the [ __ ]
out of it you're in candy the last he
was over it the last fight was a draw
and I think many people thought that was
a rigged I think personally I think
Logan's gonna win Logan's gonna win he's
like a girl he's like a foot taller they
just way bigger he's heavier you know I
mean and yeah he's been training for
like a year at this point
all he does you don't tell me I you know
I don't usually admit this but I do kind
of guide you never mind I got a piece so
bad all right let's wrap it up it is
cheeseburger fries cheeseburger fries
all right done we doing this yeah cut me
up love you guys see on Friday ha ha
[Music]